in the UK we we don't have a
presidential system I I don't want
somebody who you go oh that's our great
leader
um I think Nicholas sturgeon governed
like that and I think it's been a
disaster she has left my country
absolutely devastated I think Kate
Forbes has a slight possibility of being
able to rebuild it precisely because of
our Christian values K Forbes was
interviewed recently and I saw her five
questions on sex
you know what nerve I mean people go oh
you Christians are all obsessed by sex
we're not obsessed by it
it's the media that are obsessed by sex
nothing about industry nothing about
farming nothing about education nothing
about the NHS and I know what the people
of Scotland care more about and it's
certainly not Progressive issues that
seem to
this bubble that people seem to live in
that they're not the issues that we're
concerned about